wondering your thoughts on my husband's problem. When he gets bit by any kind of bug or gets in the
poison ivy or poison oak or crate vernal tree, he will have the itchy redness and swelling at the
bite and guttex site, but then there are other areas where he was not but their touch by plants
that he has learned to. Do you think the histamine pills would help produce eliminate this systemic
itchy problem? So why would a person that why would a person be hypersensitive to different
poison this plants? Okay, so most people if they get the oil and them from poison ivy or poison
oak will, you know, create, you know, their skin will be irritated by it, they'll get hives,
it'll be itchy and if they itch it, they touch other areas, they're spreading it all over.
Most people will have that experience, but some people end up with a hyper reaction,
so they, you know, it gets all over their body and it's their whole body becomes inflate.
And they might be, they might have been told that they're very allergic to that thing,
which may be true. You can, your body can develop antibodies to a toxin.
So, okay, so let's take a step back. So when you, when you're, when you get an infection,
so let's say you're exposed to a strep, you know, strep throat, your daughter comes home from
school, she had strep throat, you breathe it in, that's a bacteria. So that bacteria enters your
body, you end up with an immune reaction, so that acute immune, immune reaction is what's called
a TH1 response. It causes this up tick of inflammatory chemicals called cytokines.
Your histamine response may kick in for even a pathogen and it, it calls in these immune cells
to kill the pathogen. But let's say it's a particularly virulent strain of strep that you've
never seen before in your body, and you get quite sick and you get a fever, that's a hyper TH1
response, that's good. Because you need that TH1 response to bring in these, these immune cells
to kill that pathogen. And then let's say it's, you know, your health wasn't really good, your stress
was high at that point in time, and you get really sick, so you have to take the next day off of work,
you got a really bad sore throat, but you didn't go get any antibiotics, you just kind of weighed
through the course and you drank some chicken soup and you slowly recovered. What happens in your
body is that the TH1 response isn't able to kill it in about 24 to 48 hours, it will suppress
that. You'll kick in this B cell response or a TH2 response, and that's responsible for making
antibodies against that strep. You want to do that. If you have antibodies now circulating against
that strep, it's going to take that strep and you're going to be able to better kill it.
Better even more important is now you have those circulating antibodies and they don't
dissipate, you know, they can stay with you for years. And now every time, let's say two months
from now, you get exposed to that same strep or even a similar strain, you have those antibodies to
take it and you're able to kill it quicker, you never do get sick. And you're like, oh, I have a great
immune system, I don't get sick. Well, it makes a great immune system is you have a lot of antibodies
to a lot of pathogens. So therefore, you never get a fever, you don't feel ill because those antibodies
will take those pathogens that you're exposed to, you're still exposed to just as many pathogens as
anybody else. But I don't get sick because I have these circulated antibodies that take that
pathogens, so my immune system could kill it quite readily. Problem comes in is that when you create
antibodies to things that are not living. So toxins, poisons from plants, poisons from our environment
are not living organisms. So if I develop antibodies to those non-living organisms,
I'm going to create this inflammatory response, which is not going to be good. So an inflammatory
response to a toxin is not really helpful. It is said that it's going to kill the toxin because
it toxins aren't killable. So the purpose of our body to create an inflammatory response to like a
poison IV is to keep us away from going into that grove where the poison IV was. So it keeps us safe
so that we won't go into something to be exposed to a poison that could damage cells and
could kill us. So that's the purpose of an inflammatory response. A person that has a hyperinflammatory
response to these things may have developed antibodies. If you develop IgG antibodies,
you'll end up with this hyper response every time you're exposed to it. Some people even
develop IgG antibodies, which that is a very hyper response at the time of exposure that could
cause all sorts of things and could put somebody at anaphylactic shock and could potentially cause
death because of the inflammation after exposure. So that's somebody with an IgE reaction to
peanuts per se. But you can have IgE reactions. You can have IgE antibodies to mold. Those are
the people that walk into moldy buildings and go, oh my gosh, I can't take it. I can't be in here.
I got to get out of here. I got to leave. But everybody else is like, what is wrong with you? I don't
smell mold. If they have IgE antibodies to mold, they are a high percentage of the mold. They'll smell
mold when nobody else smells mold. And they've got to get out of that situation where they feel like
their throat's going to close out. The same thing can be true when you're exposed to environmental
things. So how do you deal with these things? Well, you try to know that you're hyper inflating to
these things. You know that you, and it can be different things. So let's say a deer fly. Some people
can be hyper reacted to deer flies, but they're not hyper reacted to horse flies, two different
types of flies, but they have different venom. Some people can be hyper reactive to poison,
though, but they're not hyper reacted to something else. So you know, how do you deal with this then?
Well, once you know it, you have to try to prevent the exposure. Number two, you should have
an epiphen, just to make sure that you don't have, have ever developed IgE reactions. So you can
prevent, you know, serious condition if you're exposed to these things. Number three, taking
antihistamines can be beneficial. Over the counter, antihistamines, medications, I mean, taking
antihistamines supplements can be beneficial. So what's in like our clear histamine scavenger is
quercetin and large bark and a bunch of different things that are known to help pull these, those
toxins out of your body, pull histamines out of your body to calm down mass cells. Mass cells are the
cells that make this histamine and cause this inflammatory reaction. So long story long answer to, you know,
what I could have done quite quickly is the answer. Yes, these things may help, but I would also caution you
you know, you can't develop IgE antibodies to things over time, if you're exposed to these things.
So having like an epiphen may be a safe thing to do as well.